so it's not the stock or the asset its
knowledge that makes you rich or poor
you know if you want to stay small be
the smartest guy on the block every time
I fail at minimum I won't get smarter
when you see stuff like that you know
how can I quit I never want a job I
don't ever want to work for anybody else
and I don't want to work for money you
don't marry the first man or woman you
meet
hopefully you kiss a couple of oatmeal
before you do I make a lot of money but
I give a lot why struggle for money when
you don't have to
I don't watch over I didn't know who she
was the people that are winning are
people like me who understand debt with
perspectives that often contradict
conventional wisdom he's known for a
straight talk his courage and as a
reverence he has challenged and changed
the way tens of millions of people think
about money he's Robert Kiyosaki and
here are his top ten interviews mentor
me Robert
the first one you say that I thought was
really interesting is that money is
knowledge right Mikkel back again you
know most people say save money well
there's no longer money after 1971 so
today if you're saving money when bonds
are paying zero and the Fed is printing
trillions saving money is really bad
advice so but everybody is now saving
which is the worst time to save so you
can lose if you had bought gold in 1980
you would have lost money you can buy
real estate and lose money you can buy
stocks and lose money so it's not the
stock or the asset it's knowledge that
makes you rich or poor because a true
investor can make a lot of money on the
markets up will make more money when the
markets down for what right now this is
my best time ever
bad economies so this is the secret is
you've done your research you've done
your homework
you know where you should be putting
your money well it's common sense that
Marcus don't always go up you know and
most people buy hold and pray for the
long term that's insanity on this
volatility all right so knowledge inform
yourself and that's become powerful
you know if you want to stay small be
the smartest guy on the block and that's
why most accountants most attorneys most
doctors never get rich it's because
they're too narrow you know they're
experts in toenail removal or something
you know I mean or my attorney that got
poor guys at a student ID knows jack
about side of them whereas I never had
em on I fought the high school twice I
can't write its irony I'm a writer today
but the reason I'm pretty good is
because in the military we're taught to
be generalists not specialists so when I
sit down with my team I have accountants
I have attorneys I have media guys I
have IT guys I have graphic designers
and all this so I operate as a team
since I don't know anything so in
actuality being a great entrepreneur
means I could be the laziest guy and I
can know the least but I have to have a
very smart team which is the ring finger
around me so because I was never smart I
had respect for people who are smart and
a lot of times I meet a students and
they think that the smartest guys on
planet earth and that lack of respect
look you from small and that's what most
corporate guys want to do stay small you
know you gotta climb that corporate
ladder you gotta beat the other guys
with a job and it's all that stuff it's
not the way an entrepreneur only works
it's it's corporate it's school system
you know you kind of beat up from the
grades kind of best grades I don't have
to be the best but I have to hang out
with the best
we had fast cars and very fast lemon and
we took our mind off of the business and
the business came crashing down so when
people said ask me when it wasn't
undercapitalization was it this wasn't
that I said no it was good-looking women
the most fun 3 years of my life I highly
recommended but I was depressed for
about five six years because I had to
pay back I didn't declare bankruptcy I
paid back the money so I spent the next
million dollars and I just kept chugging
away making the money and so one of the
reasons I became a good entrepreneur was
actually straightening out the company
figuring out what I did wrong
mistakes I made and I couldn't pay back
the million dollars as an employee so I
kind of forced me to stay in the as an
entrepreneur and become a better
entrepreneur so the failure was really a
great thing in the end so today I'm not
afraid of failing because every time I
fail at minimum I won't get smarter when
I get smart I make more money next time
and that's what an entrepreneur does
is there a time to bail out on a prize
oh I mean when I don't that's not in my
vocabulary yeah
look I have a I have an unfair advantage
you know I went to war and at war I'm
alive because other guys died for me
when you see stuff like that you know
how can I quit most guys I just wimps
[ __ ] cowards they don't have it so
they should say should get a job
but please hear me this is the thing I'm
trying to say to people it's how you
think I never want a job I don't ever
want to work for anybody else and I
don't want to work for money my money
works for me
and people work for me until you can
make that shift you'll always be poor a
middle-class so until that shift comes
unless I swear I'll never work for
anybody any more that I'm going to be
the guy that owns the plantation and
today I own large companies of oil
companies mining companies publishing
companies and all this but that is the
most important thing you see if you need
money then your soul is weak if you need
if you need to go and say I need I need
a paycheck
I need job security I want better job
benefits the government should take care
of me you don't have a prayer and my
question has always been why don't we
teach kids about money at school I
totally agree with that why don't we
have like finance something like a
listing 101 when you're in the 5th 6th
7th 8th how about high school none of
that none but there's a reason they
don't teach you that is because
otherwise we would have no employees
that's the reason they want to make sure
that you're silly enough to just keep
working hard you see if you're an
employee you're in a different tax
bracket than me
you know percentage-wise you'll pay more
in taxes than I will pay did you know
that absolutely if you work for money
the harder you work well money you make
the more your taxes go up right ok so
when I work my taxes can go down more
money I make
everyone says finding good real estate
is hard when you're getting started
what's the value of good network and
good partnerships well I'll say it again
in 1973 I came back from Vietnam and I
was a pilot out there and I took a real
estate course there was $385 three days
long and that's a lot of money back then
I was only making $500 a month so 385
was all I had and the instructor then
though the program said to me he said
what did the whole class full of 30 of
us he says your education begins now
that you leave the class even get
educated wild the class so his
assignment was that everybody over 30 of
us with the Parapan team get up in teams
to the two or three a team and went to
look at a 100 properties in 90 days and
he says don't buy anything just look at
a hundred properties doing evaluation of
each property write-up write a short
blurb about it why it's good why it's
bad and it's at the end of 90 days and a
hundred properties then you make up your
mind if you're going to buy something he
says if you haven't found one property
in a hundred a hundred deals you start
again you know you start again with
another hundred and that's what most
that's why most people are not rich
they're not willing to go through that
process of looking at a hundred deals to
find one deal and this sometimes in you
and I know you look at a lot of frogs to
find one princess you know but when you
find that one princess everybody goes oh
well how do you get so lucky well I
looked at a lot of dirt dirt dogs out
there you know and that's like anything
in life you don't marry the first man or
woman you meet hopefully you kiss a
couple of them you know before you do
my seam you know
what the heck with people think about
money but that's what I get a lot of is
kind of this well you know money is not
spiritual I'm just saying it's your
attitudes you know a person's attitude
towards money I make a lot of money but
I give a lot you know what I mean in
fact it goes to biblical principle the
more you give the more you receive so
when I meet somebody who is not doesn't
have any money it just means that
they're not giving something yeah you
know so a lot of times there's people
who would like more but they're not
giving anything so they're like my poor
debt you know he belonged to the labor
unions and he wanted to work less and
get paid more well that's anti-religious
to me yeah if you want to get paid more
work more give more that's how I see it
my message to people is you know why
struggle for money when you don't have
to you know it's that really simple you
have good advice the problem is money is
not taught in school and so what we do
is we oftentimes following our parents
footsteps we may do different jobs but
we oftentimes follow in the same
financial patterns and my rich dad used
to say you know I said you can't you
can't end poverty by giving somebody
money giving a poor person money keeps
some poor longer yeah and that's what
breaks my heart
because I want to help people change the
way they think about money that's all it
is
yeah and I think one of the most
important things is that I noticed when
my rich dad my poor dad was the
vocabulary my poor dad you know the PhD
in education very smart man but he had
the vocabulary of a schoolteacher and my
Rich Dad had the vocabulary of a rich
man and so when I see the people what's
the fun you mean by vocabulary well I
know what the word means but what kind
of vocabulary well maybe my I stood
around the dinner table and listen to
both dads and one would talk about
algebra and geometry and trigonometry
any money my rich dad would sit there
and he talked about return on investment
assets liabilities discount cash flows
well you say you know what you just said
about your house is a liability it's not
an asset most people think it is their
biggest investment yes and that's the
one the biggest middle-class traps they
said my banker says my house is an asset
and my rich dad would say if you can
read a financial statement you'll see
you can read that your house is actually
a liability I'm not saying don't buy a
house and I like big houses I like the
finer things of life just don't call a
liability in acid and what's trapping
the middle class is thereby liabilities
you think about
is your advice to other entrepreneurs to
be searching for a big break and if so
how what's your advice on how to for
them for them to position themselves in
the best way to increase the chances to
get a big break well I can I say that -
I hear that five things going for and
when you're prepared it happens but if
you're not prepared it doesn't happen
for example you know I was out here in
Ozzie when Oprah called I didn't start
preparing when she called you know and I
was prepared when she called and my wife
calls up and says hey Oprah come I go so
what she says well she wants you on a
program I go so cuz you know real men
don't watch hope yes watch all four not
me you know I mean I don't watch over I
didn't know who she was
it's more since get your butt home now
so I fly all the way from the bush way
inland from Brisbane to Brisbane to
Phoenix to Chicago and I'm sitting on
over it's too late to practice
yeah you know so but I have done so many
PR stunts you know something like this
here and practice practice practice
practice practice and so when all the
lights went on oh my god this is it it's
too late to practice and I learned that
in the military as a pilot in Vietnam
you know I don't say well I should I
should have spent a little harder before
I got to Vietnam I've got a practice
practice practice practice practice
because when that ball of Viacom was
shooting at me you know there's only one
guy going home that day him or me
and that is too late to practice and
what happens for most entrepreneurs so
they don't have the skills they don't
practice it there's a very good book
called outliers the story of success I
think it's the best book for
entrepreneurs because it talks how the
Beatles became the Beatles you know they
played war than any other band in
history they played for almost for free
and what Frankfurt Hamburg wherever they
were and the average person doesn't
practice enough okay great advice
how do we take your teachings and apply
them to ourselves to make sure that we
are not victims and we are part of the
solution rather than part of the problem
is exactly the words I would use what
fuller says we're supposed to be
architects to the future not not its
victims that was when the final quotes
in this book the second chances in three
parts past present and future and the
reason I recommend part three which is
the future is financial education
because what you'll find is everything
they teach in school it is opposite to
what my rich dad taught me I don't save
money why would I save money when
they're printing money why would I save
money when they given me
you know at that's 2% why would it
invest for the long term when those
front running high frequency training in
all this you know why would I get a job
when people pay the highest taxes our
jobs people with employees so everything
is the opposite so what happened I write
about in second chance it's a 1971 Nixon
took us off the gold standard at that
point the US dollar became debt so it
makes it hard for under people to
understand the people that are winning
are people like me who understand debt
you see debt is the name of the game to
gain today not money that's what this
guy Philip is saving look Baba Zimbabwe
the debtors are winning see most people
use debt to consume you car new house
new cellphone your clothes credit card
debt but I use debt to invest that most
people say that's dangerous and it is
but that's why financial education
should teach you how to use debt to
invest particularly now again Sweden
interest rates has said that oh I just
you know when the market crash in 2007
when hit hit a high in October 14 2007
and went down a crash is good you see I
started to buy stuff at bargain basement
prices but I used debt to buy it you you
you concerned about the stock market but
there are times when it's it offers
value absolutely and that's that's why I
you know I don't hate anybody you know I
love my banker a lot of the JSE I love
the stock market you know that's where I
got my money from I love my insurance
because they give me money because I can
use debt they want debtors as a
difference is the opposite in thinking I
don't save money I use debt
thank you so much for watching we would
love to know which of the interviews had
the biggest impact on you leave a
comment below and we'll join in the
conversation soon even though that's
your line that's all good
I believe and we're out can I can i
that's what you want to do yeah that's
it we're done
what's the Bucky fuller said you must
trust your intuition you know and it's
called your gut feeling a lot of the
times and scientists have just recently
found out there's actually a brain
material in their gut that's why you get
a bad feeling and that's kind of the
where intuition comes from or from your
gut rather than your brain and my
intuition kind of change because I went
to Vietnam twice I was a good marine
Marine US Marine pilot and all this I
was doing it for God country in America
you know all this stuff and one day I
was standing on the battlefield in 1972
and I said what am I doing here you know
why am i killing these people I don't
hate them they don't hate me and that's
when my life you know you started me
started waking up as you grow older so I
learned to trust my intuition and say
what I had to say click like this book
is about the future also follows a
futurist so for me to write Rich Dad
Poor Dad in 1997 nearly 20 years ago
was about the future it wasn't about
1997
I think the Muslim the most important
thing we have to do is we have to
convert to solar power as quickly as
possible yeah because what cables what
keeps people poor as guys like me
selling oil all the time yeah you know
as soon as a solar power there will be
more wealth on planet Earth there'll be
less destruction less environmental
damage but there are people who don't
want solar or wind or tidal energy to
come in and as soon as that happens
they'll be greater wealth right now it
cost too much money to live mmm you know
it cost too much money to drive a car
you know yeah well affects everything
fix food clothing lights so the other
thing with when people say live below
your means you don't like to live below
your means too ya know
and I think when you say to somebody low
below you means you wipe their spirit
out it's like saying somebody if we
won't lose weight go on a starvation
diet it doesn't make you healthier to
starve yourself so I would rather get
financially educated that's why I read
read your books because I want to
this is my greatest asset I want to feed
my brain so that I can expand my means
without getting into excessive debt or
where I start to lose because debt I
could say is a to a sort but telling
somebody to live below your means is
almost inhumane I never felt good doing
it
I wanted to strive to do better every
day I want to do better every day I
liked a good life look I tell the story
of taxiing underneath your jet and I
thought I was in my jet but it was a
little Learjet I look up and there's a
727 the night taxi under it as a whole
it's it's big boys and their toys but
nonetheless it inspired me I said okay
I'm in a Learjet now it's time to step
up and it doesn't mean the jet will make
me happier what makes me happier is the
wanting to get better to get smarter to
do better